Hey y'all,
you phenoms and filibusters coffee on a
Tuesday and Vlog 56.
Yeah,
so I cheated a lot in high school and
college usually was by the old classic
method of just looking over at the
person's test next to you.
Sometimes I'd write information on a
little crib sheet or save stuff in my
trusty ti 83 calculator and I do vaguely
remember trying to steal tests from a
teacher's desk once though I can't be
sure if that was only something I saw in
a movie.
Oh,
thank you.
Mostly I cheated on tests or homework.
Never really on term papers.
I never plagiarize for some reason.
Getting caught plagiarizing seemed like
the worst thing that could happen to you
when I was in school.
Although for my very final paper in
college,
I did hand in my roommate's history
essay on the Nazis.
I was taking a sociology class,
but you know the Nazis,
they really cover a lot of ground
already.
I haven't spent a lot of time thinking
about it since really I didn't think
about it much at the time.
I suppose I just knew that the old adage
cheaters never win,
which just a cracker because I cheated
and one now I don't encourage cheating,
of course not,
but it is a part of my life and I think
it's worth exploring a little bit more.
Cheating is simply acting dishonestly to
gain an advantage in high school.
What was the advantage that I wanted or
thought I needed to gain?
Well,
where I went to school,
the primary purpose of school was not to
learn,
although that was not a negative upshot.
The primary purpose of school was to get
good grades so we could get into a good
college,
so when we graduated we'd have the
empirically proven advantage of getting
a good job so we wouldn't be degenerate.
The motivational structures were
achingly clear.
The point was to get good grades,
not to get good grades.
Honestly,
the only reason to act honestly was that
you wouldn't run the risk of getting
caught cheating,
which would after all,
injure your ability to achieve the goal
in the first place.
The ironic thing is that so pressured as
we were to achieve the good grade and
the good college and the good job,
we saw no qualms in cheating to get
there and having cheated to get there
and having got there with the good job
in a world where cheating is much,
much less viable.
We all have work ethics that are
absolute and we're all that much closer
to being degenerate.
Sometimes I laugh about that randomly on
the subway or just walking down the
street and people look at me strangely,
but it's just the kind of joke that's
too damn funny to keep in,
you know?
Can you blame me for cheating?
Of course you can.
I cheated and I'm not the only one.
A rutgers study from way back in 1997
before there were sat prep courses that
surveyed 1800 people in nine state
university's found that three fourths,
three out of four people cheated on
exams were written and you can blame
them too.
But the epidemic of cheating in school,
in science,
in sports is something that we're all on
the hook for.
And let's never buy into that bullshit
that I am the only one responsible for
my actions.
Or you or the only one responsible for
yours.
We're all responsible for one another in
each active cheating.
We performed a cost benefit analysis.
Think of the 16 year old me taking that
physics exam.
If I get caught,
I may get a bad grade on the test,
a call home to my parents or detention.
Detention is nothing,
uh,
call into to my parents sucks,
but they only want me to get good
grades.
And a bad grade sucks too.
But my teachers and my school was what
my parents wanted for me to succeed.
If I don't get caught,
I'll have successfully bypass work that
I didn't want to do in the first place.
And I'll have moved further down that
motivational yellow brick road that
leads to a good career.
And of course,
uh,
or you know,
the upper middleclass version of us,
which is,
I don't know,
a fondue maker,
just watch madmen cheating is an
activity latent in all nature as a way
for organisms to gain an advantage
without incurring the costs of effort.
I was reading recently that pseudomonas
bacteria exploit the goods generated by
cooperating bacteria without sharing in
the production.
Those bastards fish cheap primates
cheat.
We cheat on tests,
on diets on the Tour de France,
on spouses,
uh,
but there's the rub.
Infidelity is a kind of cheating that
it's impossible for us to justify,
right?
Because it's the abuse of relationships
for personal gain.
It's easy for us to feel why it's wrong
to exploit another person,
especially someone so invested in us as
a significant other for a cheap thrill.
As we move out of the educational system
with it's painfully mistaken
motivational cues,
it becomes clear to us.
It became clear to me that this is the
foundation of all kinds of cheating,
the leveraging of another person for
personal betterment.
And we all know how levers work as
someone moves up someone else somewhere,
perhaps by subtle conduits gets pushed
down.
This I suspect,
is the true meaning of that adage.
Cheaters never win,
even if you get away with it out there,
even if you're not aware of the
consequences of your actions,
you can never truly get away with it in
here.
But for the sake of honesty and a less
rainbow sunset,
everything is lovely.
And we'll work out ending to this vlog.
Let me ask you cheater,
have you gotten away with it?
Not just my work as a.
hi everyone.
Sorry the Vlog is so late this week.
The reason is that I was sent up to
Boston earlier this week to cover the
marathon bombing story.
Um,
a surreal and unexpected week to be
sure.
Um,
so thanks for sticking with it.
Hopefully we can get back on schedule
for next week and,
um,
I'll see you next time.